rencontre avec le père fondateur de la
préhistoire en touraine le spécialiste
de l'archéologie préhistorique
c'est lui jean-claude marqué fouilleurs
émérite ancien directeur du musée du
grand pressigny et découvreur de ce que
l'on appelle désormais le masque de la
roche cottard
cette partie qui est arrondi correspond
à l'emplacement où les normes percuteur
a frappé sur le plan de frappe de
nucléus
avec lui chaque caillou raconte une
histoire jean claude marquet a passé la
moitié de sa carrière ici en terre
précis mienne sur des chantiers de
fouilles ou à la tête du musée met ses
connaissances
souviens plus vaste
la grotte de la roche cottard près de
langeais autre haut lieu de la
préhistoire en touraine la grotte de la
roche que tarbes on l a été découverte
en 1912 personne n'y avait retravaillé
avant moi à la fin des années 70 avant
de partir au grand pressigny là où on
avait besoin de moi mais dès que j'ai eu
terminé au grand pressigny mon premier
souci c'était de revenir à la rochepot
tard pour poursuivre le travail qui
était entrepris sur ce niveau où nous
nous trouvons les hommes de néandertal
se sont venus ils se sont déplacés au
dessus de cette ligne là le rocher est
plutôt grisâtre c'est tout simplement
parce que la loire a envahi la grotte et
à ce moment là les hommes ne pouvaient
plus rentrer à l'intérieur de la cavité
et ce sont les hyènes qui ont pris
possession du lieu à l'entrée de la
grotte néandertal a laissé de nombreux
autres traces de son passage des outils
qui nous laisse imaginer ces hommes
préhistoriques installés ici il y à 40
mille ans sur une plage de loire
c'est là que jean claude a fait sa plus
grande découverte un masque de silex
l'homme a fait passer dans le trou une
esquilles dos qui est entre mes deux
doigts à la cette hausse a été bloqué à
l'intérieur du trou grâce à deux petits
cailloux plat qui dépasse ici que l'on
voit très bien ici c'est l'une des
quatre ou cinq proto figurines qui ont
été découvertes en europe et qui datent
de l'homme de néandertal c'est pour ça
que cet objet est un objet très très
important et donc par mme parole par
conséquence le site de la roche que tard
à langeais en touraine est un site
vraiment très très important
oui